and aaron luke
filling the role of the opener today he
has been fantastic signed a one-year
three million dollar deal and for all
the talk we've uh uh
spewed about uh taiwan walker this year
and what a great bargain he's been and
he has been loop under the radar has
been a remarkable piece for the mets
in that stellar bullpen and he strikes
out adam frazier with a change up and
that's how loops day begins and mr
reynolds will bat now
and he strikes out reynolds looking on a
fastball a one two three opening inning
for luke with a couple of strikeouts
that's what an oprah is supposed to do
they'll be going up against chase to
young and in seven starts he's one and
three with a 508 14 walks and 30
strikeouts and 33 and two thirds and it
gives the mitch an immediate threat as
francisco lindor steps in
and he cranks this one to deep right
center field forget that
parks one deep into the bullpen a 2-1
shot for francisco and the meds have an
instant two-nothing lead he said he said
he had a great swing at the previous
pitch and he had an even better sling on
this one his 11th home run of the year
his second in this series
first and second one out michael
conforto coming up
and he drives one to deep center field
back goes reynolds to the warning track
back at the wall it's out of here
michael conforto unloads a three-run
homer five to nothing new york in the
first inning his first home run since
the first of may 89 home 89 at bats
without a home run the longest drought
of his career
and that has been obliterated and now
the eighth man to hit against chase de
young is the catcher james mccann there
we go and the young rebounds to get the
final two outs a five run first inning
lindor and conforto and the pirates have
first and second one out and another
switch hitter rodolfo castro coming up
double play ball in door with the flip
mcneal with the turn six four three
double play and that gets luke through
the top of the second it is billy
mckinney pinch hitting chase de young
the pitch
breaking ball swung on and missed his
second strikeout went away in the bottom
of the second oh and to the count on
brandon nimmo
breaking ball swung on and missed third
straight strikeout two away in the
second michael perez has caught three of
the four games in this series
that's line but right at lindor in the
shift and he reaches out to grab it for
the first out a bullet off the bout of
perez one away balls no strikes on
newman runner at first base is frasier
pitch
bouncing ball softly hit to third vr
waits grabs it throws it across in time
he gets newman by a step and the inning
is over john nagowski bats here with a
runner on first nobody out
that's a ground ball back to iclove a
chance for two mcneal with the turn one
four three double play second double
play for the mets this afternoon two out
of nobody on ammo left-handed batter fly
to left his first time 3-2 that's driven
to center field nemo started back now
he's there and he puts it away to retire
the side ahead and nobody left that's
cruising with a five-nothing lead in the
fourth
3-2 pitch breaking ball drilled to right
center field
toward the fence and the catch is made
on the track by wilmer defoe right
fielder for the pirates now they want
ikoff to go several innings here today
so he'll bat
an easy play for de young in a one two
three inning he's sent down seven in a
row
and through four still five nothing new
york now rodolfo castro he bounced into
a six four three double play
there we go waited for a good pitch to
hit and he rips it out to right center
and gone another home run for rodolfo
castro
well he looks awfully promising yes he
does nice power in that left-handed
swing and he fell off a couple of them
but finally got one out over the plate
that he could handle and he put a good
swing on it this kid's got a beautiful
left-handed swing then a 3-1 count on
perez
i cops pitch
perez cracks one to left center field
sending nimmo back to the wall and this
one is off the top of the fence
and cares to shallow center field and it
is a home run it hits off just above the
yellow line a home run for perez over
the left center field wall to make it a
5-2 game that's number six for perez and
nimmo tried to do it again
tried to time it up this one just hit a
little out of his reach so frazier goes
to third newman the second brian
reynolds the batter now
and he loops one into center field
coming on quickly as nimbo but it'll be
caught and the side retired ball stayed
up for nimmo reynolds is out familia
gets the out he needs and the mets lead
5-2 but now here's gamel who's o for his
last 10 having flied to left and then
flied to center 2-2 coming to gamel
and he flies one out to center field
overcomes nemo toward left center and
he's got it two out defoe takes inside
ball four brings up rodolfo castro
and hit out to left
rodolfo castro showing off his power he
goes up oh he's over twice
in two innings
welcome to the future it is now look at
that how much fun are we having on the
baseball field right now we got
ourselves a ball game five to four in
the top of the six and rodolfo castro
with another swing in the bat jeff
mcneal the lead off
inside and mcneil is hit and that one
hurts
trainers staying in the dugout that's a
good sign
the batter is james mccann
and he strengths out mccann looking so
two strikeouts looking for austin davis
in relief
and now brian reynolds will be the
batter the one guy in this lineup that
really can strike fear in a pitching
staff is reynolds reynolds drives one
out to center nimmo back of stride he's
there and that retires the side so
castro works his way through the top of
the seventh off walk brandon nimmo is
one for three
and there's a nice play and a double
play
turned by rodolfo castro what a great
play at third he's doing it all today
fantastic play he threw that off his
back foot watch him go up and just like
you said joe got the ball out of his
glove as quick as possible made a good
throw and that loads him up so the
go-ahead run now is in scoring position
and michael perez who is homered in this
game will be the better
that's all the outside corner the
backdoor slider got him perez is furious
as he's punched out by jeremy rehack
a big call goes diaz's way for the
second half and now cabrian hayes will
be the pinch hitter for stratton struck
him out and when diaz finds his way out
of the jab back-to-back strikeouts of
perez and hayes to keep the match in
front by a run well it's john nagowski
to the plate for the pirates with two
outs and a runner at third
and a robot's throw john nagoski ties it
off edwin diaz in the ninth inning it
was inevitable you just felt it it was
going to happen somehow some way
somebody was going to come through
and who else but the big nagowski it's
first and third the buckos now have the
go ahead run 90 feet away for wilmer
defoe
yes and they've done it they've taken
the lead
three straight two out hits
nigalski gamble and defoe follow
newman's double and the pirates have
turned this game right around
and now it's nimo the lefty hitter
for the ground you might get two out of
this
two down on the double play
it worked out for the better lindor who
has not been put out today
[Music]
underneath it and out to right
oliva just in the game
the glasses are off the ball is caught
and the first half concludes like that a
come from behind pirates win in the
ninth inning
and how about those bucks